wenn peter und seine kollegen ihre
nachtschicht im vergnügungsviertel von
frankfurt sachsenhausen beginnen dann
gehen sie so sagen sie vorbereitet in
dieses wochenende mit circa 30 mann sind
sie dann unterwegs das sei notwendig
sagt peter und beschimpfungen seien im
laufe der nacht fast noch das
harmloseste
mitten in unserem interview sagt dieser
vorbeilaufende man lieber rasch ein
schimpfwort das peter zur genüge kennt
und sich das nicht mehr gefallen lässt
eine personenkontrolle zigarette aus was
fällt ihnen ein an polizeibeamten
vorbeizulaufen und iwf zu rufen ich
einen kollegen
wir wollen wir erzählen dass sie es
nicht gesagt hätten doch habe ich gesagt
haben wir uns dann aber zu meinen
kollegen natürlich was bedeutet lieber
helfen wissen sie dass ich zeigen oder
neuss oder wissen in welchen sie war
schon zur zeit auf
aber
so ganz richtig ist dass nicht die welt
wird umgangssprachlich als ungeziefer
benutzt ja und ja die leute legen zwar
waren die respektlosigkeit müssen wir
die uns nicht geben und die
erfahrungsgemäß sind das auch die leute
mit denen wir dann nachher noch mehr
stress
das ist tagtäglich und das ist
normalität geworden
könnt ihr heute durch lassen
platz machen brenzlig wird es vor allem
später in der nacht wenn der
alkoholpegel bei einigen deutlich
gestiegen ist und auf andere drogen hoch
im kurs sind
sie haben die möglichkeit nach hause
wenn die zumeist jungen leute wie dieser
mann dann platzverweise etwa wegen
aggressiven verhaltens erhalten und dem
nicht nachkommen droht der abtransport
in polizeigewahrsam
dieser mann der offenbar drogen genommen
hat wehrt sich und wird ausfallen
die gefährliche momente waren nicht weiß
regt die personen sich in auf und ist
von ihm geben her so dass sie sich viel
bewegt oder aber kommt gleich in der
nächsten sekunde der andere und
tatsächlich der meinige klanglich
bespuckte die beamten und randaliert
nicht sagen unberechenbar und
unvorhersehbar und in dem moment zählt
es kann ja nicht nur sich selbst zu
schützen sondern auch möglichst im
bewegungsradius der person möglichst
gering zu halten damit sie personen sich
auch nicht selber von uns solche szenen
sind alltag für peter und seinen
kollegen die durch platzverweise dafür
sorgen wollen dass leute die gefährlich
werden könnten aus dem verkehr gezogen
werden
wie diese zwei männer die beim
drogenkonsum erwischt wurden und dann
auch noch eine scharfe messerklinge
dabei haben
über ungefähr anderthalb zentimeter lang
und selbst die reicht vollends um dann
mit lebensgefährliche verletzung hervor
zugesicherte umfassend auch wir machen
das jetzt so
sie verlassen jetzt in altenkirchen
doch was passiert wenn sie das nicht tun
wenn wir sie noch mal antreffen vor 6
uhr morgen früh mit genau den segeln
genommen
das verstehe ich das kann sie wirklich
zu bespucken beschimpfungen gewalt gegen
polizisten
peter sagt das alles habe in den letzten
jahren zugenommen
seit elf jahren ist er im job dann mache
ihn weiterhin sehr gerne aber manchmal
sei er eine ganz schöne herausforderung
diesen mann kennen sie alle
er ist oft wegen gewalttätigkeiten
aufgefallen und lässt sich auch von dem
heutigen platzverweis nicht beeindrucken
bespuckt hatte die beamten auch nachdem
die polizisten ihn zum letzten mal
verwarnt hatten kollegen der jede
kollegin ist genau so angeekelt wenn er
angesprochen wird oder angesetzt wird
wie jeder andere aufgaben es macht
trotzdem was man eher ruhig bleiben
selbst die maßnahmen die die belanglos
innerhalb eines monats annähernd 100
strafanzeigen haben die beamten
aufgenommen und gleichzeitig rund 40
verletzte polizisten registriert 50
beschuldigte wurden festgenommen
natürlich wisse er sagt peter dass es
auch verfehlungen von polizisten gebe
aber er warnt davor sie alle unter
generalverdacht zu stellen
er wünscht sich mehr vertrauen und auch
mehr respekt